بعد اخفقه في 6 جولات سابقه مجلس نواب
الامريكي يعلق اعماله الى منتصف اليوم
لانتخاب رئيس
كيف تكشفوا ان حطام وسياره اراديه يحتوي
على اجزاء صنعتها 13 شركه امريكيه
مقرفه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
الانباء من العربيه
بسبب خلافات بين الاغلبيه الجمهوريه ولم
يتمكن
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب الذي سيطر عليه
الجمهوريون بعد الانتخابات النصفيه
في سابقه تسجل منذ قرن فشل الجمهوريون في
اختيار رئيسا لمجلس النواب الامريكي خلال
عده جلسات رغم فوزهم في الانتخابات
النصفيه في نوفمبر الماضي
هو بحسب راي العلاقه الشخصيه السيئه بينهم
الان هو فقط موعد الحساب
جلسات مجلس النواب او مابات يعرف الان
بالكارثه اثبتت حاله الفوضى التي يعيشها
الحزب الجمهوري واضعف شخصيه الرئيس بغض
النظر عن النتيجه التي سيتم التوصل اليها
عكس الواقع الذي فرضته المراه الحديديه
نانسي بيلوسي
الاول
من جميع الاطراف وهذا سيكون خيارا صعبا
للغايه
مع غياب لاي منافس جاد لمكارسي عكس
اليومين الاولين لسيطره الحزب الجمهوري
على المجلس الصعوبات التي تواجه اغلبيتهم
متحده في مواجهه الرئيس جودا الامر الذي
سيتيح هامشا من المناورات الديمقراطيين
الذين يتوجسون من بدء منافسهم تحقيقات
تنال من الرئيس وافراد عائلته بانتظار
صفقات قد تسمح لهم بالحصول على ما فشلوا
بالحصول عليه في الانتخابات النصفيه
[تصفيق]
اللافت بكل ما يحصل حتى اللحظه تبقى
مطالبه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بدعم
ماكرتي التي لم تلقى اي استجابه لدى نواب
تجمع الحريه الامر الذي يطرح المزيد من
علامات الاستفهام حول تاثير ترامب على
الحزب الجمهوري في هذه المرحله ريتا
سليمان العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
وتقعد هذا المره الاولى التي لا يتم فيها
التصويت على رئيس مجلس النواب من التصويت
الاول منذ سنه
1923 ماذا حدث
[موسيقى]
الجمهوريه دان كريم فقط
قبل ذلك الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب الجمهوريين الى دعم ترشيحين لمنصيب
رئيس مجلس النواب ترامب
لا تحولوا نصرا عظيما الى هزيمه عملاقه
ومحرجه
رئيس المجلس النواب يعكس صوره سلبيه عن
البلاد
صحفيه عن امله في ان يتمكن الجمهوريون من
الاتفاق واختياري رئيس للمجلس
اعلن البيت الابيض من الولايات المتحده لا
تاسف لمقتل عدد كبير من العسكريين الروس
في ضربه صاروخيه نفذها الجيش الاوكراني
ليله راس السنه وقال المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي
في البيت الابيض انه ليس هناك اي تحصر من
جانب الاداره الامريكيه لان الاوكرانيين
تعرضوا للغزو وهم يقاومون ويدافعون عن
انفسهم على حد قوله ولم يعلق على حصيله
القتل التي اقرت بها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في حين اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان الحصيله
اكبر بكثير مما اعلى توبسكو وتبلغ 400
قتيل
و300 جريح
شكلت الهواتف المحموله سبب الرئيسيه لسقوط
عشره القتلى جراء ضبط صاخيه الاوكرانيه
التي استهدفت الجنود الروس في ماكيب كام
ما يثير صورها حول اليه عمل تلك الهواء
في المعركه تاتيك الضربه من كل مكان لا
تدري اين مكمان الخطر والخطر قد يكون من
الهواتف الجوال
تصدر الهواتف الجواله اشارات عند
استخدامها من قبل الجنود
تتصل تلك الاشارات بشبكه الخلويه للجهه
المقابله ما يسمح عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
بتحديد مكان وموقع الجنود
تلقائيا يتم حفظ معلومات رقم معرفه الجهاز
ورقم التجوال وبالطبع تحركات الجنود
استقبال تلك المعلومات يتم عبر اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه تتوفر لها قدرات
هائله للرصد والمتابعه يتم ارسال
الاحداثيات التي تم التوصل اليها للقوات
الاوكرانيه
لتستفيد من تلك المعلومات في ضرب مواقع
الجنود بالصواريخ او المسيارات
طريقه اخرى باستخدام منظومه لير 3 المكونه
من طائرتين مسيرتين ومركز قياده في شاحنه
عسكريه لتتبع مواقع الهاتف ويمكن لهذه
المنظومه رصد اكثر من الفيهاتف محمول في
مدن يصل الى خمسه كيلو مترات واربع مئه
متر مما يتيح امكانيه العثور على مجموعه
كامله من القوه الروسيه كاشف مواقع القوات
المنافسه يتم ايضا من خلال استخدام اجهزه
راديو وواي فاي وبلوتوث وعدم تشفير
الملفات الحساسه وتنزيل التطبيقات غير
الموثقه
خطا يقع فيه الكثير من الجنود والنتيجه
فقدان ارواحهم بيد هواتفهم المحموله التي
تطلق عليهم طلقه مميته
اشرف الريس الروسيه امس بنفسه على انطلاق
سفينه الحربيه تحمل صواريخ تسرقون
تحمل مصلحه قويه وستؤمن لروسيا مصالحها
كما ستحميها من التهديد
في مجمع الصناعات الدفاعيه الذين ابتكروا
الانتاج الدخل لهذا السلاح الفريد كما قلت
بالفعل لا يوجد مثيل له في اي دوله في
العالم انا متاكد من ان هذا السلاح القوي
سيسمحه لروسيا بحمايه نفسها من التهديدات
الخارجيه المحتمله بشكل موثوق وسيساعدنا
في خدمه المصالح الوطنيه لبلدنا
عشان انت لسه ما شفناش استراليا
عن تقرير المخابرات الاوكرانيه قوله ان
حطام وسياره ايرانيه واسقطت في اوكرانيا
كان يحتوي على اجزاء صنعه ثلاثه عشره شركه
امريكيه بالطبع اضافه الى شركات عربيه
غربيه اخرى طبقا لتقييم المخابرات فان من
بين اثنتين او 52 مكونه استخرجها خبراء
اوكرانيون من سياره ايرانيه هناك 40 مكونا
صلعتها 13 شركاتنا ملكيه ونقلت سان
اندرسون
سيارات الايرانيه من خلال العقوبه
وما استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا تعتمد
روسيا كثيرا على الطائرات بدون طيار
طائرات تستوردها بوسكو من ايران التي تقوم
بتجميعها اعتمادا على مصادر متعدده وحسب
التقديرات تتجاوز تكلفه اسقاط المسياره
الواحده سبع مرات ان تكلفه الاطلاق الامر
الذي يستنزف فيه
الحروب استراتيجيه وخطتها تحدث فوارقه
مهمه على الارض وان كانت من السماء في
اوكرانيا الامور لا تخرج عن هذه المعادله
روسيا من الجو راهن على ارهاق اوكرانيا في
الارض من خلال الطائرات بدون طيار المفخخه
رخيصه الثمن التي تجلبها من ايران والتي
تقوم بتجميعها من عده مصادر
تدمير الاهداف الاوكرانيه الى استنزافيا
فكلفه اسقاط مسيره واحده تبلغ اكثر بسبع
مرات من اطلاقها
رغم ان مهاره الاوكرانيين تزداد في تدمير
مسيرات الا ان خبراء عسكريين يقولون ان
ذلك قد يكون لمصلحه موسكو على المدى
الطويل فالطائرات بدون طيار ذاتيه التدمير
يمكن ان تكلف ما لا يقل عن 20,000 دولار
لانتاجها في حين ان تكلفه اطلاق صاروخ ارض
جو يمكن ان تتراوح من 140.000 دولار
لصاروخ اس 300 من الحقبه السوفياتيه الى
500,000 دولار لصاروخ هايمارس
وفق تقديرات اطلقت روسيا نحو 600 طائره
مسيره منذ بدايه سبتمبر الماضي وبالغه
الارقام تحتاج اوكرانيا اموالا طائله لصد
هذه الطائرات التي تكون اثارها التدميريه
تفادحه على اوكرانيا حاله وصولها الى
اهدافها
بلال الوجديني العربيه
تعهد الرئيس الفلسطيني
اي تفاصيل حول حجم او توقيت ارسال شحنات
المدرعات المخطط لها
رفضت الخارجيه الروسيه هي دور الايطالي
ان ايطاليا لا يمكن ان تكون وسيطا في
الازمه لانها تساعد النظام الاوكراني
وتتخذ موقفا عدائيا مناهضا لروسيا على حد
وصفها
وقع وزير الدفاع البولانتي اتفاقا لشراء
شحنه ثانيه من دبابات يابرانزا القتاليه
الامريكيه في الوقت الذي تسعى به وارسو
لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه وتكثيف في
تعاونها العسكري مع واشنطن في ضوء حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا وقال مسؤولون بولندا
اول خليفه للولايات المتحده في اوروبا
ثيران وعلى الرغم من الاعدامات المستمره
في حق المحتاجين شدد المرشد الاعلى
الايراني علي خامنئي على اهميه مشاركه
النساء في عمليه صنع القرار في البلاد
معتدل انه يجب ايجاد طريقه لتطبيق تلك
المشاركه ونقلت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه
الرسميه للانباء من اي قوله ان توظيف نساء
ايران التي وصفهن بالحكيمات والخبيرات في
مختلف مستويات صنع القرار في البلاد موضوع
يحظى بالاهميه وعلى القادم في ايران تحقيق
ذلك
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بيني وبين
نتنياه وانا اسرائيل سوف تتصرفوا بحزم
وقوه
لجاضه التموضع الايراني العسكري في سوريا
واضافه
ايران تطوير خرسانه النوويه بطرق مختلفه
وبشكل المهني وعلني امام الراي العام
العالمي
اول اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره الى ملكيه
حيث شدد باسرائيل بفعل كل ما يلزم لمنع
ايران من الحصول على اسلحه النوويه اداره
دوري
ما فيها في مشروع ولكن بعد قليل
رئيسه ماذون يقول ان تخفيضات في الوظائف
في شركه ستطالب اكثر من 18,000
اهلا بكم من جديد
على اهميه الحوار بين المكونات السياسيه
كسبيل للخروج من حاله الجنود التي تعيشها
البلاد
لحوار الوطني
اغلقت تشكيلات المسلحه ليبيه طريق الساحلي
في منطقه تاجوره بسيارات العسكريه
العربيه
والكتيبه الحاديه والخمسين بقياده بشير
خلف الله
اعلان
توسيع وتطوير الدوريات المشتركه مع روسيا
في شمال سوريا
وسوريا في الفتره المقبله حول الوضعي على
الحدود
انتقدت منظمه الصحه العالميه تعريف الصين
الجديد الضيق للغايه على حد تعبيرها
للوفيات الناجمه عن كفر مؤقته ان
الاحصائيات لا تنسجب مع عوده انتشار
الوفاء في البلاد
مجدده المنظمات عيدها اجراء فحوصات على
القادمين من الصين المدير العام للمنظمه
بكين بضروره تقديم بيانات المنتظمه وسريعه
حول الوضع الوبائي في البلاد معبرا عن
قلقه من تزايد الاصابات
الصين
لا تعكس حقيقه انتشار المرض في اراضي
اوصل الاتحاد الاوروبي الدول الاعضاء بفرض
اختباري كورونا بنتيجه سلبيه تقول له مدته
48 ساعه على المسافرين الوافدين من الصين
ذلك في بيان اصدره الاتحاد عقب اجتماع
لصياغه ردق على تزايد اصابات كورونا في
الصين واشار البيان الى الاتفاق على توصيه
كل المسافرين في رحلات المتجهه الى الصين
او اتيت منها بوضع كمامه كما اوصى التكتل
الدول الاعضاء
الصرف في المطارات التي تستقبل رحلات
الدوليه وتلك الموجوده في الطائرات الاتيه
من الصين
وكانت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا
بيربوك حتى على ضروره التنسيق المشترك مع
منظمه الصحه العالميه بشان مواجهه اوروبا
لموجه كورونا قادمه من الصين
هدفنا ايجاد حل مشترك ويجب ان نتعامل مع
هذه الموجه القادمه من الصين بجديه
بالبالغه ولن نتحدث عن تعاون الاوروبي فقط
بلد تعاون مع منظمه الصحه العالميه ايضا
من اجل الشفافيه الكامله حول الوضع في
الصين
كم اشترطت فرنسا تقديمها نتيجه اختبار
تثبت الخلوه من الاصابه بقبل 19 على
القادمين من الصين قال المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الفرنسيه
لحمايه المواطنين من الاصابه
الى الصيني
والتضحيه التي بذلت على مدى السنوات
قبل 48 سنه
في الاثنين انتقد المدير العام للاتحاد
الدولي الجوي وضع قيود على سفر القادمين
من الصين وقال ان هذه التدابير اثبتت عدم
فعاليتها سابقا
المكاتب الهجينه المطارات المقيده
سيناريوهات تعيد الى الاذهان ذكريات لم
يتجاوزها كثيرون حتى الان والعالم لن
يتحمل مثيلاتها مره اخرى حسب خبراء
تدابير لا يريد الكثير من الناس التفكير
بها ولكن الاجراءات التي فرضتها بعض دول
العالم على القادمين من الصين اخيرا
اعادتها الى الواجهه الصين بدورها هددت
بتدابير مضاد
مستعدون للتواصل مع العالم للتغلب على
رائحه كورونا ولكننا نعتقد ان قيود الدخول
التي فرضتها بعض الدول على الصين تفتقر
الى الاساس العلمي
لاتحاد الدولي للنقل الى التعليم
لحمايه المواطنين وهي مبنيه على قواعد
الصحه العامه واتخذت بعد استشارات مع
خبراء من عده دول اجراءات اختبرها العالم
لثلاث سنوات مضت بين الانظمه الصحيه
والاقتصاديه تعلمت من هذه التجارب واصبحت
اكثر خبره في التعامل مع هذه الانواع من
الازمات
يرى خبراء الصحه والاقتصاد وتتحدث عنه
الدراسات التي اجريت بعد ان ضربت الجائحه
انظمه واقتصادات الدول في مقتل
اعلن الرئيس
في الشركه ستطالب اكثر من 18 الف وظيفه في
اطار تقليص للقوى العامله وبدات الشركه
التي
لها تسريح الموظفين بقسم الاجهزه في
نوفمبر الماضي
تم الاعلام الدولي بشكل غير مسبوق بحفل
تقديم النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
لاعبا جديدا لنادي النصر على ارضيه ملعب
مرسول مبارك بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض في
بيالي استعرض ابرز عناوين الصحف والمواقع
العالميه التي تحدث او تحدثت عن هذا
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
في نهايه هذه النشاط تذكير
سابقه
اعماله الى منتصف اليوم الانتخابي رئيس
كيف تكشفوا ان حطام وسياره ايرانيه يحتوي
على اجزاء صنعتها ثلاثه عشره شركه امريكيه
نخاف من الدراع اشتباكات في تاجرات
الليبيه بعد انتشار كثيف لتشكيلات وسط
دائما المزيد على العربيه
[موسيقى]